can he be more ambitious that's the  question after f4  oh he's got his streaming face on uh  again looking off to the left  calculating  i think he's gonna take it i think  you're right you did  let me grab the  [Music]  the mouse  yeah  okay moment of truth to take or not to  take on g7  i mean he's looking at that square he's  shaking his head  he's  counting now  it's gonna be bishop takes g7 i don't  think he wants the tension of f4 and  there we go  and there we go  there we go we have it on the board  yeah and  ding reacts instantly  he goes all the way shaking his head  shaking his body  i mean he definitely calculated this all  earlier he wasn't working it out now but  uh he knows the cameras are wrong  what would you do here is ding would you  repeat just take the draw or would you  go in for that kind of risky line that  we saw well it was not risky for him i  think  not